hey guys greg here
so um
right now it is 1 29 in the morning i
could not sleep something i got an email
at midnight about something
got into a chat with someone from
creator support who i could tell was a
real person by the kind of back and
forth we were
actually having with one another because
sometimes you're like is this a bot or
not
you know uh is wow
if this is your first time watching the
channel welcome i guess weird video to
be watching for the first time um
but i know a lot of times you know with
youtube a lot of us get concerned about
watch time and all that
i'm gonna ask you guys just flat out
please stick around
for the whole video or as much as you
can
because i learned something from this
conversation
with this individual at creator support
that for the first time and i know a lot
of people
a lot of creators bigger than myself
have
no clue that this is a possibility and
it's something that
happened to me today and
i was pretty uh shocked to learn this
information and i got clarity from
jt from creator support several times
but i think it's really important to
hear out because
there's been a lot of things that have
made me go maybe we should look into
other platforms yada yada but this was
the
first time where i truly was
terrified into oh man there's nothing
any of us i'm talking about all of us
anyone who's been around youtube for
several years
there's nothing we can do to prevent
this from happening to us so here's what
happened
i'll tell you what led me here and then
i'll tell you what it is
because it's probably something that
most of you are not aware of that
ultimately affects all creators
okay here it goes a few years ago uh
this channel i used to go by little
personality alter ego
called uh ryan wright now for those who
were
around during that time you'll know how
that personality alter ego is a little
bit different than
than myself a lot more of a perverted
personality
and edgy for lack of a better word right
so there's a lot of videos in the past
uh that have been age restricted or just
removed from youtube like a lot of
individuals who have been dealing with
community guideline implementations
uh i myself have had a lot of that
happen with
many of the videos from the past and
i've just sort of accepted that like
that's going to be the case with like
so many of the videos by like the years
of videos basically either from things
that i actually did in the video or
things i even just
said age restricted or removed and i i
actually
usually understand but there's one
particular video that was a sketch
called alyssa fool's day that uh john
and i shot together
and alyssa ferrari is like the star of
the sketch with me
it's a spoof it's a sketch on prank
videos and it gets
really absurd and really out there and
it actually took a lot of
work and a lot of time a lot of
dedication to put this video together
got like 120 000 views and i i was
really proud
of the video but there's some things in
it where i was like i
i totally get why youtube page
restricted this i had no
no complaints there and it was removed
from youtube a while ago actually i just
wanted to get the video so i could
download it
and because i was like you know that's
like a lot of hard work and this is the
only place i know where this video
exists so i just want to i just want to
download the video and i saw that it was
still
in my video manager even though i
couldn't view it so i had the option to
send an appeal
to like argue for why my video should be
reinstated basically
and what i said in my appeal was i just
want to be able to access this video so
i can download it and i don't mind
having it be removed from youtube or
deleting
i get i was just trying to be as
compliant as possible and in actuality
my other goal with it was sometimes in
certain cases if you like dispute
something you can get access to it so
i thought if i send in an appeal i could
at least get a temporary access to this
video
so then i can download it right there in
the moment i wasn't able to
so minutes later after sending in my
appeal
i just deleted it from my video manager
i hit the permanently
delete button this was around 6 p.m
six hours later midnight i get an email
from youtube and it's the first thing
that shows up when i log into youtube
i'm getting ready to go to bed
i'm proud of myself because i haven't
really been sleeping much i'm like i'm
going to bed at midnight this is kind of
early for me this email is basically
saying
we have reviewed your video and uh it
violates community guideline violations
this is your warning
next time this is a strike and that got
me worried because the strike means i
wouldn't be able to access the channel
for
pretty much a week we wouldn't be able
to upload it i wouldn't be able to live
stream
basically wouldn't be have any access to
the way
we make a living here right that was
really concerning for me because uh
my friend tyrone magnus he had an issue
happen with him where he got a community
guideline strike wasn't able to access
his channel for a week
and you know you get a couple more of
those and it's bye bye youtube so that's
not exactly what i'm here to tell you
guys about because i was just trying to
everything i told you i i got a creative
support i was just trying to clarify
that with them
of what my intentions were with the
appeal how i deleted the video
and how it was confused how were they
able
to review a video six hours later
that i had permanently deleted
that was the really confusing part
to me the video was deleted though i
don't understand and here's what i found
out
from this individual name jt who i did
say i'm prob
i did say if i did a video about this is
that okay
and they said as long as there's a
violet community guideline violations
then all right and i don't think i have
in this video
so i will share with you guys what jt
said without going through all the
boring stuff here's the
important part jt said as i previously
mentioned deleting your content does not
exempt the content
from a strike and i thought they were
saying
that i got a strike and then i tried
deleting the video and i know that
doesn't remove a strike
so i said to jt i was an issue to strike
jt responded furthermore
as i previously mentioned we may also
issue a community guideline strike
on deleted content
yes we understand mistakes happen and
you don't mean to violate our policies
that's why the first violation
is usually a warning now that you only
be worn once and this warning will
remain on your channel
the next time your content is found to
violate the community guidelines
you'll get a strike so videos from my
past videos that i delete
can suddenly get a community guideline
strike
even though they are removed jt said
that is correct you may check this
article that they do
and may this serve as a lesson for you
to be more mindful of the content that
you post on your channel
as i previously mentioned sometimes this
wow i just hate reading that
as i previously mentioned sometimes a
single case of severe abuse will result
in channel termination without warning
and i said at one point got it so to
clarify
it doesn't matter if i go back and
delete videos from six years ago
that i myself go oh this is a cause for
a concern with youtube's newest
censorship rules
i could still get a flag flag or strike
from them they said i'm afraid to sew
so what i learned from this conversation
was
that i can delete videos i can go to
videos
from years ago when youtube wasn't as
strict with their censorship rules and
their community guideline rules and all
the other
crap they have implemented now i can go
there and delete those videos
and then they can still come at me and
give me a strike
and this isn't just me this is everyone
on the platform everyone
and i'm like well i have gone through
so many videos so many
because man did i do a lot of stuff i've
gone through so many videos even ones
that were hit with age restriction and i
just set them to private and i'm like
okay it doesn't even matter they're
private it doesn't even matter they're
deleted
i can still get my channel shut down
from a commit from
from a video that is deleted
what that doesn't make any sense to me
how can you protect yourself from that
we don't have
we're 838 000 subs we don't have a
youtube account manager
we have to get invited into that manager
program it's such a random thing and
that's like you know i don't want to go
too much into other people's business
but i have friends who were in trouble
and they were able to rely on their
youtube account manager or i think
that's what the representative position
is called and they could call on them
for help to help them speed up the
process to fixing some [ __ ]
for me for for us
we don't have that so
i just got a whole bunch of videos like
it doesn't even matter if they're
private or deleted
they might just go community guidelines
strike if baffled me that they would
issue me this
warning which is essentially like a
pre-strike on the elissa fool's day
video
which is a hilarious ass video by the
way i just might add i don't understand
how they could issue me that
when i permanently deleted the video six
hours before they reviewed it and then
they're telling me that they can
flat out just give me a strike off of a
video
that is deleted like this
ah
how's anyone say from this how are any
of your favorite creators with like
millions of followers say from this
people have been around for like many
many years and i know i'm not the only
ones who got in trouble with youtube but
i don't think a lot of people are aware
of the fact that this can happen to
deleted videos
what fighting chance do you do does
youtube really give you
you know that's
scary
may the ryan right days live on in glory
and thank god i stopped doing that stuff
huh anyway
i'm happy to be greg alba though and uh
you know it's uh it could be more
sincere and have talks like this
thank you guys for listening this is i
think really important for people to
know because i talked with some people
who didn't know about this either and
uh yeah there's a reason it's kept me up
all night
i don't know how to end this thanks for
listening see you guys